I'm an sworn this is my friend you'll
what's uh we own a production company
here at Towson University in Towson
Maryland our main objective is to create
content that educates entertains and
inspires our generation and future
generations to come
how can I help you guys something that
we wanted to ask because we did ask this
technically yesterday I don't know if
you see on the board but we have like
different news media's it's all bad
literally we've been calling since like
7:00 a.m. this morning okay I wanna get
them to know about the event that we're
doing so thank you trying to gain some
more traction there my question to you
is if we were trying to get someone to
really make this thing work because we
really want to provide as much value as
we can - okay
not just creators but sort of Baltimore
City Public Schools okay how do we go
about doing it in your opinion so wine I
would pick one thing mm-hmm I would pick
one thing so like I already forgot the
three things that yours that you staying
for like create and educate but like the
clarity is super important people won't
remember yes and to remember three
things they won't so like pick pick the
one thing like what is your mission
what do you try to accomplish one one
see just we want people to care about
each other again great so you're
launching a campaign that's it like we
want people to care I can remember that
antwon's the guy who wants people if
they care about each other again like
great I love it this is great where do
you have more clarity then picking a
project like the spotlight thing the
school thing alrighty it's like talking
about too much stuff so pick the one
project that you really want to get
going and so if it's a school project
antwuan wants to get people to care
about each other in school and we are
launching this one day in September or
whatever for people to know about it
great now now it's easy for people to
kind of twig and understand okay so
because I have to give the reception
because I didn't tell them like you said
if I'm something everybody this whole
thing is gonna like distract them and
get them a little confused about what's
going on
I just need to get to the point and just
tell them that part it's fine it's all
over the place but it's okay right like
just make it better now and you it's you
stand for something important I want you
just to lead with that
I want people to care more about each
other in Baltimore okay that's what I
stand for right now it's what I'm trying
to accomplish right and that's like
that's a message that people can really
get behind anybody in Baltimore is gonna
gonna love you right who's gonna say no
like we don't we don't need to care
about each other that's stupid right
forget those people but that's the
message that people can relate to in
this and then they say okay well how do
you how do we make that happen
Antoine what's the what's the path and
then well you say listen we start in the
school system and we're doing this event
in September and here's what we're gonna
do right so leaving with that making it
super clear is gonna be the easiest
first step calling on the media is is
great so obviously it's like it's local
media right it's all Baltimore area
people yes sir got it and then I would
are you looking at just the general line
news line are you targeting individual
reporters we actually were targeting
individual reporters because it turns
out there's a special reporter I'm at
the Baltimore Sun Yahoo it does allow
the special interest pieces for that
Baltimore City yeah and she told me of
another person who was working on the
same type of project yeah and this woman
raised $50,000 through a GoFundMe yeah
um and she was like yeah you know you
should really link up with her because
obviously she knows what to do to raise
money for this right so what about that
first person is she gonna cover you yes
she is
okay great so that's one right all right
that's why I listen if you're so
targeting individual reporters is
definitely the way to go
okay look through every every local
newspaper magazine community paper even
within Baltimore the different the
different sectors the different
different geographic areas they all have
their own little local paper connect
with those with the individual reporters
a lot of them are on Twitter reporters
live on Twitter I think you may be they
may be on IG too
but reporters on Twitter I would reach
out to them with a Twitter video I think
you come off really well on video like I
thought your energy comes through okay
in an amazing way like I might I might
maybe go to a school or something and
like shoot them from outside of school
right Oh something that I also was
thinking about was because I already
told my friend this and we're working on
it right now is we're a production
company why are we sending email
invitations to anyone I mean we can send
emails out but what we should really do
is send video catered towards that
particular person or something like that
video invitations yeah like um one thing
that we're doing and this is actually
pretty cool is that we wanted to get
Gary banner shut to come to the event
because Gary is in New York is not too
far from Baltimore in Maryland so what
we were gonna do was make a parody of
his first Wine Library video guy and do
it like an invitation to send to him and
do it through like Twitter and like
there's a girl who has like a Facebook
group page who's like really friends
would hit the guy and really you know
knows him a little bit so she was saying
that's a great idea too because that's
how you get his attention it's by doing
things along that nature you see what I
mean if you have the skills you can do
it you have to spend the work to get on
that person's radar I would see that as
a long-term play uh-huh like if Gary
doesn't say yes to come into this event
that has to be okay but you got a longer
term plan for maybe maybe you go to New
York and you interview or the next time
is that Baltimore like definitely any
that the chances of Gary taking time out
like he's got a busy calendar he's not
coming to Baltimore for this thing but
it's okay right like as long as you're
thinking it longer down the road what I
would through though is hack the system
and look at any people who are coming to
Baltimore for a speaking event look at
the any convention centers that are
happening look at their event calendar
see who's speaking there and if any of
them are anybody that you would want to
come to the event because if they're
already in the city it's a lot easier
for them to pop by your place and say hi
for the event
okay people are not likely to make a
special trip out to see this but if
they're already coming to the city the
Metro Convention Center website will
have a list of their events and who's
speaking there so I'll be trying to
target those people it doesn't even have
to be super high production I think you
will Wayne off your authenticity like I
think you guys play really well on video
I would just go to a school and spend
like spend this afternoon drive to the
closest school and spend the entire
afternoon making one-minute videos on
Twitter sending it to customize people
and say hey it's it's Antwan annual and
we're doing this event that's it and
just like Winston repeat and spend the
entire day doing it I think you have a
better success with that then than just
sending out cold emails to people yeah
and I agree because I was saying you
know we have to stick to our strengths
and that's something that you really
taught me because I've been watching you
since I want to say guys 2012 may be
2013 and that's something a lot of you
guys have taught me is that it's all
about self belief and it's all about you
know that's the reason why I really love
your messages of Belize yeah because if
you don't believe anything I don't give
a damn what tactics you use it's not
gonna work it's not gonna work at the
end you have to believe in yourself
that's reason why you know we listen to
guys like you guys like Gary and
everybody else is because we want to
believe in ourselves and we do that's
reason why were chasing big ideas and
big dreams like this we even have the
old mentor who's friends with Carmelo
man Carmelo Anthony and okay he said
he's gonna talk to him personally and
try to get him to come to the charity
event as well great and again it's a
long-term play like if Melo can't make
it cuz he's got some other thing going
on yeah then then you have the
connection and this is this is a
long-term mission for you guys just my
dog is trying to get on my lap here are
you gonna just Anathoth hi
if twitter is gonna be your path if
you're gonna be doing a lot of these
video dm's you need to spend the next 4
hours outside some school damming people
before you do that make a one-minute
video of you talking
about what your this cause is all about
why it's so important to you post that
to your Twitter and then pin it to the
top so that any of these people who you
DM if they have any kind of interest the
next step for them is gonna be going to
your Twitter profile and then they're
gonna see like what's that thing at the
top and if there's another video they're
talking about why this is so important
to you then they've seen your one-minute
your video message now they've seen your
one-minute clip I think Twitter might be
45 seconds I just double-check that but
that's the next step I'd also make sure
your Twitter bio is something that's
highly targeted to this thing you're
putting on it was like two guys with the
dream or something like make it more
specific to what you're trying to do a
lot of the Twitter buyers just suck like
make it super targeted for this thing
that you're doing because that's what
they're gonna do they're gonna watch
your video like listen half the people
won't even watch it that's fine forget
them the other half will watch the video
some of them will think okay that might
be interesting and they're gonna click
on your profile right who are these
people that's what I would do I click on
your profile so what is your then your
bio right what's the website that people
gonna click to and then you're pinned
post at the top your most recent posts
up there I would put a great video and
doesn't like I wouldn't get caught up in
doing five days of production quality
making a great video like you guys in
the video you just standing outside of
school and talking about why you're
doing this why is so important to you in
the community of Baltimore that we need
to care about each other like that's the
video and then you go off and do but you
could do that today like make that your
first video spend half an hour doing it
like eight times get the best one post
at the Twitter and then do your four
hours of reaching out to reporters and
influencers in the Baltimore area who
can help spread your message for you yes
sir
all right you I appreciate that quick
question for you before I go young IG TV
what where do you see that going in your
opinion I don't know man it's early
we'll see try it I posted my first one
yesterday I'm gonna be posting a couple
other ones I'm waiting to get feedback
and stats and analytics and all that
kind of stuff to see how it's going
there's two paths there's be the first
be the pioneer and and try everything
and
then you don't have to be good you don't
have to be good if you're the first you
just have to be first and you'll get
like if you post videos now you will get
attention and traction you could start a
whole I G TV campaign around caring for
one another and you don't even have to
be that good on camera you will start
getting attention
I don't usually follow that path I like
to come into markets that are already
established and then just be better
right so I will win because I'm good now
you can be both you can be first and you
can be good right when I was spending my
time still on YouTube I want to hit 10
million on YouTube
I want to grow my Instagram platform
right I'm only like 13,000 something now
right like I'm I'm I'm new to Instagram
and so I'm building that up by doing
what I'm doing like four times a week
going live and six times a day putting
posts out I'm pushing it hard and I'm
putting as much koalas I came into it
I'm probably not gonna play that much
with IG TV to be honest like I'll be put
in a video a week into IG to doing
something like that just to test it and
get my feet wet and see and if it starts
blowing up I will shift my resources to
IG TV but I I don't typically go down
the Pioneer I'm the first to try stuff
out I would rather go into a market with
Luzerne a ton of people and then just be
better okay I agree I agree and thank
you I appreciate the help each factor
what's that man quick question flow
state versus forcing yourself to create
yeah so here's what I do most most days
I'm not in I don't wake up in a flow
state so I I schedule creativity I
schedule my week like if you look at my
calendar it's packed everyday you know
Tuesday's my YouTube day as an example
and so I'm I'm making content for my
youtube channel I'm thinking strategy
and thinking new creative ideas that
being said when the flow state hits me I
will try to push everything in my
calendar to stay there as much as
possible so if like today CEO day for me
I got a whole bunch of different
projects if I get hit with a great idea
that I'm gonna do for my youtube channel
I'm gonna try to cancel everything on
Friday as much as possible to focus on
that thing because in that state
to create gold so my answer to you is
both it's easy to fool yourself like I'm
really in the flow answering these
emails you know like you're not right so
when you're in flow state you want to
try to see there as much as possible
because you will create gold and when
you're not you have a schedule to fall
back on that still allows you to move
the ball forward on your goals so your
regular schedule you're taking all these
little micro steps and all those micro
steps add up to big steps but when
you're in flow state you might be able
to take like a giant step forward that
equals 20 of those micro steps mm-hmm so
so what do you do when you're not in
flow state is more the question if
you're not there almost well how'd it
get there I I don't I don't try to force
flow State I just go fall back to my
schedule gosh like I got stuff that I
got to do every single day and if I if I
cancel it to go and flow state then I
need to catch up in the rest of the week
to do it so I love bein I love bein flow
state but when it doesn't happen when
I'm not there I have my schedule to fall
back on and stay productive so almost
stay into a maker ritual like daily or
whatever it may be stick to it and
you're more likely to hit your flow or
hit ideas naturally that should come to
you yeah I think if you're moving and
you're you're creating stuff I think
you're more likely to fall into a flow
state if you're sitting on the couch
frustrated and angry like I'm not in
flow I'm not I don't think that's how
you get the flow mmm I think by doing
the work so often - this is my youtube
day I may not be in flow on YouTube
stuff but then I go out to dinner with
my wife and then an idea comes to me of
something that I was thinking about
earlier right and then maybe the next
day I or even that night like I'll stay
up till 3:00 in the morning working on
that thing because I'm in flow and this
has to get done because gold will happen
from it so I think I think you land into
the flow state bye bye still being
productive by still doing work by still
moving the ball forward in small ways on
your goals I think if you get frustrated
and stressed out that you're not in flow
state I don't think that gets you any
closer to being a flow state I think it
does the opposite so let's go thank you
for taking my call all right good luck
man thank you
if you want to know what myself and
other successful entrepreneurs think
about how to build confidence check out
my 250 for confidence series where every
morning for the next 250 for mornings I
will send you a video that is 30 seconds
to 5 minutes long absolutely for free
that as you watch them it'll help you
build unstoppable confidence check out
the link in the description below
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident realizing that any
big endeavor is the collection of a lot
of small steps that came before if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee
DJ Khalid Oprah and others know about
empire building that most people miss
check out the link in the description
for a free bonus video